Speaker 1: Let's go next to Thomas from
Vietnam. What time is it in Vietnam? It
must be. Is it like 2 a.m. or something like
that? I don't even know what time it is there.
Thomas, please unmute yourself so
you can tell me what time it is.
No, boy. Thomas yourself. Me? There you go.
Speaker 3: Now. It's almost midnight
here. Almost midnight? Yeah, 10 to 12.
Speaker 1: I love it. What's going on today?
Speaker 3: All right. So with
this, Joe Biden going to be the
race for the election? Who do you think
is going to be the next nominee for the.
Democrat Party.
Speaker 1: I believe it will be Joe Biden.
Speaker 3: I know, but who who will who would
challenge Joe Biden on on a primary would be the
most likely candidate you think.
Speaker 4: Tilt.
Speaker 1: To win or to challenge.
Speaker 3: To challenge Joe Biden
on the on the primary for the Democrats.
Speaker 1: I mean, I think it's the people that
are currently running. It's Marianne Williamson
and Bobby Kennedy Jr. It doesn't seem like there's
a big appetite from serious Democratic contenders
to challenge Joe Biden. I don't think we're going
to see that.
Speaker 3:
Right. But do you think this could or could be
possibly be the biggest challenge to a Joe Biden?
Speaker 1: Oh, if they ran, who might really
be able to challenge him in a serious.
Speaker 3: Way, right? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. That's what I meant. You know.
Speaker 1: I have two views
on this. One of you is.
Another center left Democrat who's just younger
and more energizing but who isn't too far left,
would do best. So that would be an argument for
like Gavin Newsom if Gavin Newsom challenged
Joe Biden. It's someone who's not very far to
Biden's left, but he's energized and he has an
approach to dealing with Republicans that might
be more appealing. But on the on the other hand,
the name recognition isn't really fully there.
And I don't know. The other perspective is the
way to challenge Joe Biden most effectively
would be balancing being truly on the left as
some define it and being more well known. So that
would point to someone like Bernie Sanders, who is
even older than Joe Biden, even though people want
a younger person rather than an older person. But
but Bernie would be the person who would be able
to eke out the most support. My instinct is if
today you say to me, Newsom enters or Bernie
enters, I think if Bernie announces today,
he immediately picks up more support than Newsom
would against Biden. That's my view right now.
Not enough to win, not enough to win,
but more support than Newsom would get.
Speaker 3: Right. Personally, I would
love Nixon because I love his energy and.
Hello. Is his eloquence as well? And and is
he? And he provides the amount of of tenacity
that I think the Democrats really need to to
step up to the to the competition against the.
The Republicans.
Speaker 1: I love Newsom's tenacity.
I love the way he says we need to be ruthless and
all of those things. I don't know that he yet has
the name recognition to even have a shot in hell
against an incumbent president. But in an open
Democratic primary could be a different story.
Speaker 3:
Right. Right. Okay. Thank you. That's it for me.
Speaker 1: All right. Thomas from Vietnam,
very good to hear from you. So great to
hear from anyone that called in and also
anyone who called in but wasn't able to talk
to me. We will take calls again. And I so
look forward to speaking with you next time.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.